you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of what other people will think
of you if you fail but if you're afraid
of that imagine what they think of you
when you aren't even trying oh yeah they
aren't I'm such a dick sometimes um is
it is it strange to hear your angry
toilet tweets read back to you now you
know real talk the tweets that I have
people don't know this but the tweets
are notes to self so they're just
directed at me so that I can look back
on them and like be reminders of like
hey don't do that and so like I think to
myself man I'm afraid of doing this and
I'm like no I'm not I'm afraid of what
this person's going to think about me
because if I were to be able to fail in
quiet and complete isolation then I
wouldn't care and then I think well what
if I don't succeed in public what do
they think then nothing they don't think
about me at all